hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
today here on the podcast we are going
to get
rational i know that a lot of you are
thinking well it's about time
but we always try to be rational right
as i make the point early in the podcast
there are very few people
who actively brag about not being
rational but it's easier said than done
we would like to be rational but how do
you do it
how especially do you admit that you are
not always rational and reorient your
mindset
in a way that helps you be more rational
whether it's in sort of
high level problem solving for some
scientific or technical job you have
or just in your daily life who to date
what to have for dinner tonight we would
like to be rational about all of these
different choices and so
today's guest julia galliff is a star in
the
rationality community someone who has
given a lot of thought
into these real efforts that an
individual can put into
becoming more rational themselves she
doesn't want to just
give you a list of ways in which you're
not rational that's that's been done
quite a few times she wants to give you
useful actionable advice
for becoming more rational yourself so
she has a new book coming out
called the scout mindset julia's
metaphor
here is that in a war there's a military
metaphor going on here so you have
soldiers the soldier's job is to say
look i have a goal i'm going to achieve
that goal
nothing's going to stop me from
achieving that goal the other mindset
you might have is that if a scout
the scout doesn't have a goal to sort of
take over a certain installation or
whatever win a certain battle
the scout's mindset is to gather all the
possible information with an open mind
to be as open as possible to all the
different pieces of information
whether or not they reinforce what the
scout already believes and so julie is
hoping that we can all develop more of a
scout mindset
so a lot of the podcast episode is going
to be exactly that
how do you develop this scout mindset
how do you actually
train your brain to be open to all the
information
but there's an interesting
sub-conversation we have about
justifying what seems to be obvious
namely that being rational
is good so there are people out there
both explicitly and implicitly who make
arguments that you know rationality is
overrated right that in fact there's
something
maybe evolutionarily useful in being
irrational in the right way and so julia
is going to
defend the position that we should be
rational in the right way
all the time and you know that's an
extreme position but
i think i'm pretty much in favor of this
one i think that we're on the same side
so i try my best
to uh play the devil's advocate here but
overall i'm more or less sympathetic
so occasional reminder you know we have
a webpage for the podcast
preposterousuniverse.com
podcast which is a good place to go
because we have full transcripts for
every episode
and they're searchable you can search
for any word that has ever been said on
mindscape and find it in the transcripts
on the website
and the other thing is you know we like
it when you leave reviews
of the podcast on places like apple
podcasts and things like that itunes
reviews
uh they help raise the visibility of the
podcast if you think that
the podcast is a special experience that
you want for yourself and don't want to
share it with anyone else then don't
bother
but if you think that mindscape is
something that would be great if other
people were listening to
then raising the overall level of
exposure is a good thing so i'm very
grateful to everyone who does that
so let's go
julia gallo welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so great to be here
finally
so like many of my guests you have
put yourself in a position apparently
intentionally so what i mean by that
is you're defending the idea we should
all be rational
um i had david baltimore in the podcast
a while ago he's a nobel prize winning
uh biologist and we had tr i didn't no
one knows this yet uh sorry david but
while we were talking before the podcast
we had trouble getting his microphone to
work
and i said like once you win the nobel
prize don't you constantly get crap for
like not being able to get the
microphone to work do people say like oh
i thought a nobel prize winner should
get to do that and he's like oh yeah you
have no idea it's just like that
so similarly don't you open yourself up
when you're
being pro-rational as an explicit
position like
every single thing you do people are
going to say well that wasn't very
rational was it
that is yes that is true um and that is
despite the fact that i
i try to emphasize that i i definitely
don't think of myself as perfectly
rational i don't think anybody is
perfectly rational
and i also try to have kind of a light
touch
in the way in which i'm like pushing for
rationality
um so for example what i mean by that is
um
some some advocates of rationality or
intellectual honesty or other things in
that space
they they will often claim explicitly
that everyone it's always better to be
rational or it's always better to be
to see you know the truth and i don't
think that they can actually support
that i've never heard anyone
give a defense of that claim that seems
um sufficient for how strong a claim
that is like how do you know that
everyone's always better off being
rational um
like how do you know that everyone's
happiness is maximized with a rational
view of the world in every situation
that's a strong claim
so i try not to make that strong claim
and instead i will make
more nuanced claims that i think i
actually can defend like
i i think we can be pretty confident
that people would be better off
being at least somewhat more
truth-seeking than they are by default
and i i can like explain why i think
that's the case that like on the margin
we would be better off with more truth
and less self-deception um but that's
different from claiming that everyone is
always better off all the time
you know being uh being rational that is
true but as someone who's studied
a little bit of the human psychology uh
required to
try to be more rational i'm sure you
understand that the
arguments that people are responding to
are not always the arguments that you're
actually making
this is true this is true and that's
something that
i mean it's it's always like a little
bit frustrating when people aren't
hearing the thing that you intend to be
saying
but i have i've come i made my piece
with it to uh
to a large extent in the last few years
uh
just by basically i just realized
that communication is always imperfect
and always involves some amount of
making assumptions about what the other
person meant to say
and so if if most other people
in my in a position similar to mine like
if most of the people who are advocating
for rationality or truth or
you know intellectual honesty if most of
them are saying a more extreme thing
then it's it's kind of understandable
how my listeners unless they're really
going out of their way to be super
careful
um which most people aren't most of the
time it's it's understandable why they
would hear the extreme thing even if i'm
not saying the extreme thing so i've
just kind of
i've made my piece with accepting that
people are going to hear the thing i'm
not saying and i just kind of
preempt it to whatever extent i can and
then try to explain what i'm actually
saying
that is very enrolled we should always
aim to be uh you know that generous to
our listeners but anyway
i don't want to worry too much about the
flack you're getting for this because
in some sense let me come from the
opposite direction i mean
is there anyone who self-professes
to not be rational or to not even try to
be rational or not
value rationality isn't rationality just
one of those ultimately benign values
that everyone thinks they're upholding
so uh i know i understand why you say
that
um because there are tons of people who
claim to be rational or prized
rationality or prize
you know you should always change your
mind in response to the evidence like i
always change my mind in response to the
evidence
and uh and i think very few of those
people come close to upholding the value
that they're professing
and in fact i i kind of learned this the
hard way when i was researching my
book because uh i would find these
quotes
you know i was always looking for like
good quotes or good examples for the
book and i'd find these
amazing you know quotes about
intellectual honesty
saying things like you know it's so
important to change your mind you know
when you notice you were wrong
and then i would look at the source of
the quote and i'd be like this is
so i'll just give you one example i
forget the exact quote but it was
something like you know i always
it's so important to change your mind in
response to the evidence and the the
source of the quote was
rudy giuliani
[Laughter]
uh so i was like i can't i can't put
this in my book
um so i i get what you're saying and i
basically agree
um except that there actually are a
bunch of people who
explicitly reject the like principles of
rational
thinking or intellectual honesty and i
think they they kind of fall into two
categories
one category is um
the kind of post-modernist or or maybe
in a sense romantic
school of thought where you know there
really isn't any objective truth and
it's
like all that exists is different
people's subjective realities and
any attempt to try to ferret out the
objective truth or try to
you know like
figure out why two people disagree is
doomed to failure
or it's you know an agent of like white
supremacy or
um or bigotry to to even talk about
their
their being in theory a correct answer
so that's one sense in which people
disagree with me and then
another sense is i think just kind of a
classic like
a feeling that it's more noble
to stick to your guns and
never change your mind so there's a
a metric a scale in cognitive science
called
active open-mindedness which was um
invented and popularized by john barron
and it's it's just a questionnaire about
like what how do you think people should
think so it's not really measuring how
you do things but it's just
what do you think good thinking is and
so it includes questions like
should people change their minds when
they encounter
evidence that contradicts their beliefs
and so this is the kind of questionnaire
where you would think
of course everyone would say yes to all
these questions but in fact a lot of
people say no you shouldn't change your
mind
and i think they're thinking of like i
don't know deeply held political or
religious beliefs or something and they
see value in just sticking to your guns
no matter what
so that's another kind of person who i
think disagrees with even the theory
like the theoretical idea of trying to
adjust your beliefs to the evidence
well i think that second uh category
interests me i suspect that the first
one
is pretty thin on the ground like you
have to really work hard
to find people who actively
think that being rational or finding the
truth is an instrument of oppression
i think that uh the existence i don't
know people they do a good job of
finding me i don't feel like i have to
look that hard for them well exactly i
mean i think that
uh the the few examples that there are
might stand out it's like you know
it's like using twitter as a proxy for
public opinion right you know like
you're not hearing
an unbiased sample in in some sense but
but the second one
is is interesting to me because um
i can almost see it i mean i don't agree
with that attitude but i but i
i get where they're coming from in some
interesting way and i think i think
we'll get there
uh down the road but but i do have this
feeling that
when people say you know let's be
rational you can have two sets of people
who are both saying
let's be rational let's stick to the
evidence let's draw conclusions based on
reason even though they utterly disagree
with each other right and they're
they're using it to bash the other side
so in some sense
do we agree on what it means to be
rational for one thing
is there a sense in which all right
thinking people know what they mean
when they say let's be rational
uh no i i think there's like tons of
disagreement about that
about what people mean by that word some
people mean something like
uh i don't even it's so hard to even try
to summarize what different people mean
by this
i think in practice what a lot of people
mean is you should believe what i
believe
and so anything that disagrees with me
is not rational that's like a common
uh colloquial interpretation of the word
um
there's there's you know kind of
technical definitions you could give
from philosophy or um or like economics
or computer science even
of of what like a theoretical rational
agent would how how theoretical rational
agent would update their beliefs in
response to new evidence
um or how a theoretically rational agent
would make decisions to maximize their
utility like to pursue their goals
effectively um
i but but you know any attempt to apply
those definitions to actual messy human
reasoning in the real world
is going to involve it's going to be
messy so okay
i you know i don't try that hard to come
up with a definition
of how to think rationally that is all
comprehensive
um but you know there are heuristics
like i think
i think it's pretty arguable that uh
you know trying to at least sometimes
look for reasons you might be wrong is
probably going to make your thinking
more rational than if you didn't do that
at all
uh so these you know these seem like
like pretty weak claims like well who
would disagree
but i think that the disagreement is
just in in practice how often do people
actually try to
live out these principles so as you
pointed out there are tons of people who
will agree like yeah of course of course
one should do these things but then
practice people rarely do
so yeah i'm more arguing that like we
should try to do these things that you
know
that you probably agree already in
principle are good
well you already uh alluded a couple of
times to the idea of being willing to
change your mind
in the face of evidence right and this
is closely related to the constellation
of ideas that goes under the umbrella of
bayesian
reasoning right so uh let's assume that
there are people in the audience it's
probably not very likely but there are
people in our audience who don't even
know what bayesian reasoning is i've
never heard the word baze
how would you talk about that way of
thinking sure
so bayes rule is just a simple theorem
in probability theory about
basically how you should revise your
confidence in a particular hypothesis
in response to new evidence um and
it's pretty simple it's just uh your
your confidence should go up
in proportion to the ratio of how likely
is that evidence
in a world or like how likely would you
guess that evidence is in a world where
your hypothesis is true
compared to how likely would that
evidence be in a world where your
hypothesis is false
uh so you know of course in the real
world
we don't have perfect information like
we don't know exactly how likely
uh how likely is it that this
paper in support of um wearing masks for
coronavirus
uh how likely would that paper be to
exist in a world where wearing masks
helps compared to a world where
wearing masks doesn't help we can only
guess at those things so in practice
bayesian reasoning uh just means kind of
making an attempt at least to make these
guesses and and at least get a sense of
like
you know the order of magnitude like is
this paper a lot more likely
in the world where wearing masks helps
than the world where it doesn't
if so then that's you know it's kind of
strong evidence in favor of wearing
masks
or to take another example uh
if if you read an article about how a
woman in a tech company
was passed over for a promotion because
she was a woman
how strong is that evidence in favor of
the hypothesis that
the world of tech is really sexist i
would argue it's not that strong
evidence just because when i imagine the
world in which
tech companies are not more sexist than
average i think
even in such a world it's pretty likely
that there would be at least one case of
a woman
who was passed over for a promotion due
to her gender just because in any big
industry
that kind of thing's gonna happen at
least sometimes and so i would argue
that
uh that article doesn't provide very
strong evidence
um for that hypothesis about tech being
sexist
so that's like that's one aspect in
which um i think
trying to be bajan trying to at least be
mindful of bayes rule when you're
evaluating evidence
leads to thinking that even though it's
not precise and mathematical at least
isn't i think an improvement over
default human reasoning
yeah one of the uh examples of this kind
of reasoning that i i find
people like the the basic idea that yes
if the
data you're collecting is more likely
under one hypothesis than
another hypothesis you should increase
your credence in the one that's likely
under okay
right most people are going to go along
with that at an intuitive level
but in theory well in theory no
what i what i mean is most people will
say they're going to go along with it
right rather than actually
going along with it yeah well they'll
they'll say they're going to go along
with it but then maybe and maybe this is
where you're
going to go with this i don't mean to
preempt you but i think there are a lot
of situations where people
explicitly reject that reasoning uh
if the context is like well i don't know
exactly in what context people rejected
but
but for example i've i've talked to
people who will agree with that
reasoning and theory
um and in in some contexts but then when
we're talking about like
i don't know something political like is
trump going to win or could the
democrats be right about
about immigration or something uh then
they will insist that you know nothing
could change their mind or
any evidence that comes up even if i
think it's like way more likely in the
world where the democrats are right
they will insist that it's zero evidence
at all in favor of the democrats being
right so they will
reject the idea of trying to do that
kind of estimate in their head
uh if it leads to conclusions that you
know would force them to downgrade their
belief in a particular
strongly held hypothesis well the
specific kind of
mistake that i was going to mention is
when
there is some evidence and i would argue
that it does go against someone's belief
and and all that they think is necessary
is to say no i can account for that
evidence under my belief
what they don't do is say well if the
evidence
had been the other way i would have
counted that as huge evidence for my
belief
exactly yeah i think it's like i think
it's a theorem that if the
if the opposite evidence would have
increased your belief then this evidence
should decrease it
exactly right no that's that's a great
example of a kind of
like common sense implication of bayes
rule that people
very often neglect and that you know
even if you're not plugging numbers into
a formula
just just being aware of the the rule
and the fact that it implies that
you know if if x would have been
evidence that that you would
update on then the opposite of x should
it has to like force you the other way
right even that can i think provide a
really useful corrective on your
intuitive reasoning
um on its own but what do you think
maybe
go ahead sorry i was just going to say
an example of this that maybe you're
familiar with
but maybe some of your listeners haven't
heard is during world war ii
there was a lot of concern that japanese
americans were going to
you know betray the us
in support of japan and governor
i think it was governor earl warren in
california was one of the strongest
proponents of this you know
japanese-americans are treacherous
hypothesis and he was presenting this
testimony to congress that we should
in turn japanese americans and someone
pointed out you know there hasn't really
been any evidence of
sutterfuge from japanese americans and
he said ah well i take that to be
you know even more confirmation that
they are planning centrifuge because
they're being so
uh sneaky about it that that they've
managed to hide all the evidence
and you're just like okay so it's
evidence for your view both if there is
and if it
isn't any sign of centrifuge well yeah i
mean
the the way that we see that all the
time on social media is
everyone is criticizing me therefore i
must be on to something
right right no that's a great exactly
right so you're saying that
if everyone was agreeing with you that
would mean you were wrong like
maybe in theory you believe that but in
practice i've never seen anyone actually
act that way when it comes to hiring
people it's as much about who you say
yes to
and also who you say no to so it helps
and you can narrow down the list to only
great choices first
so you're not choosing between good and
bad but between good and great that's
what you get with indeed
indeed is the job site that makes hiring
as easy as one two three you post you
screen
you interview all on indeed you can get
a quality short list of candidates whose
resumes on indeed
match your job description faster and
you can only pay for the candidates that
meet your must have qualifications
then you can schedule and complete video
interviews on
the indeed dashboard so indeed ends up
making connecting with and hiring the
right talent fast and easy
you can choose from more than 130 skills
test or add your own
then add your must have requirements so
you only pay for applications that meet
them
get started right now with a free 75
dollar sponsored job credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com mindscape offer valid through
june 30th
terms and conditions apply but i think
what we talked about
so far is sort of half of bayesian
reasoning right like you have some
beliefs
you collect more data and you update
them but then the other half is
you have some beliefs right yeah like
the people who don't like bayesian
reasoning always object to the idea that
we need to start with a prior and that
seems
that seems kind of mystical like where
do you get these prior opinions from do
you
do you have a a spiel on that or do you
have a take on
how it's necessary to have some prior
credences on things
uh no not really i mean i think the the
claim
that trying to be bajan or trying to be
mindful of bay's rule when you're
encountering new evidence the claim is
not that that will
lead to 100 accurate beliefs it's just
that
that relative to not using it it will
lead to
more accurate beliefs right so everyone
we all start out with
uh you know prior beliefs and
assumptions that just come from
whatever they come from uh where we grew
up and the people we talk to
and the whole collection of all the
sources we've read and the experiences
we've had
and and our the entirety of our life
experience has led to us having
you know a world view um and then
then the question is just given that
fact that all of us have these
prior beliefs that we can't you know
prove are true
and that are probably wrong in lots of
ways given that fact conditional on that
will we be better off if we then try to
use bayes rule
in updating on new evidence like from
that starting point of our
you know subjective and probably flawed
beliefs and i'm claiming that i think we
probably will be better off
if we you know update in a roughly
bayesian way than if we don't
but that doesn't mean we will be 100
right it just means we'll be probably be
more right than if we weren't using
bayes rule that sounds like an admirable
goal there are a lot of obstacles to
that goal and you point out some of them
uh
i've seen you put up this slide that you
call like the most depressing graph
in the world oh yeah the graph of
despair graph of despair why don't you
why do you explain that uh
so this is a graph um made by
dan kahan who is a cognitive professor
of cognitive psychology at
yale law school and it was
uh it was part of a study a series of
studies he did
um in which he measured there was a
construct that he called
i think he called it science
intelligence um but really it was just
kind of a collection of measures of
people's
scientific knowledge and basic science
basic analytical reasoning
like can you do very basic logic puzzles
and do you know the answers to basic
scientific questions like
um you know which is is the air in our
atmosphere mostly oxygen or mostly
hydrogen
things like that um and so so
he he collected this measure and
and he also collected measures of
people's political
affiliation like liberal or conservative
and their views on various ideologically
charged scientific questions
like climate change you know do you do
you agree that
like the earth is getting warmer at
least in large part due to human
activity
and so what he found was first of all
the unsurprising part was that political
views are correlated with your views on
climate change
we all know that that's surprising right
but the the surprising part and the part
that i
that made me call this the graph of
despair was that
if you if you order people on this graph
by scientific intelligence
um at the low end of scientific
intelligence
uh there's very little correlation
between political views and climate
change
so like low scientific intelligence
conservatives and liberals are both at i
don't know something like 30 or 40
percent agreement with climate change
but then as you go up the scale as
people increase in scientific
intelligence
the uh the correlation between political
views and
climate change views increases and so
the the lines of like
how conservatives feel about climate
change versus how liberals feel they
diverge
as you go up the scale of scientific
intelligence until in the
in the top tier of like the top one
percent of scientifically intelligent
people
um there's just wild disagreement over
climate change where
democrats are at almost 100 agreement
and conservatives have fallen
from 30 or 40 down to about 20 agreement
with climate change and so i mean it's
it's despairing because
you know there's this view this kind of
idealistic view i guess that if
if everyone just gets more more
education in science and more training
and logic and critical thinking
then we will all you know be able to
agree on the truth and actually this
graph shows the opposite
well the way that you i don't remember
the numbers from the graph but the way
that you reproduce them right there
it sounds like the conservatives did not
decrease by
that much in their belief in
anthropogenic
climate
[Music]
is that everyone would have converged
and so even
decreasing a little bit is kind of
shocking if you expected them to
converge in the other direction
so simply being more knowledgeable or
more educated uh doesn't make you more
rational in that particular way or
not as much as we would like yeah so
there's a
there's a popular interpretation of this
graph that i think is wrong or that i
i don't think is supported and the
popular interpretation which i think
even dan kahan the creator of this graph
has probably
said on occasion is that being smarter
and being more knowledgeable makes you
better at finding defenses of the things
you want to believe so
he's drawing kind of a causal line in
between
your scientific intelligence and like
reasoning ability on the one hand
and your ability to self-deceive
along with you know in
keeping with your political views on the
other hand i don't necessarily think
that causal line exists
um to me the most plausible explanation
for the graph of despair
is just that people with high levels of
scientific intelligence tend to be more
politically
engaged um you know they tend to be
more educated and they more educated
people tend to care more about politics
and the more you care about politics the
more hyper-aware you are of what
your side is supposed to believe in what
the other side is not supposed to
believe
and so it's not that you are better able
to deceive yourself it's just that you
on this particular topic you have more
of a motivation
to get the politically correct answer
for your side whereas the people with
quote unquote low scientific
intelligence
just aren't really that engaged in you
know
getting the politically correct answer
yeah
i think both of these hypotheses sound
actually plausible to me i'd be
interested in
collecting more data so you could
control for these uh
questions of political engagement and so
forth i do remember ezra klein was on my
podcast and we talked about political
polarization and
he made the point that it certainly
doesn't go away
uh with increased education it's sort of
the opposite in fact it's a broader
theme where you know the the pithy
statement is
nobody knows more about the tensile
strength of steel beams than 911
truthers
right right right you can really really
really be an expert in something
and have a completely crackpotty
conspiracy theory point of view on it so
i think
that sounds more like the uh position
that you're pushing against a little bit
um i don't know if that's in tension
with what i'm saying
basically what i think we can conclude
from things like the graph of despair
is that at the very least intelligence
and
and knowledge on a particular subject
does not protect you
from motivated reasoning on that subject
then the the question of whether it
actually makes
you more inclined to motivated reasoning
um is kind of a separate question that's
trickier to figure out
but but i think it's even important just
to say the the weaker claim that it
doesn't protect you because people tend
to feel like it does protect them that
you know i'm an expert in this topic
therefore my reasoning is going to be
really
you know good and objective and my
answers are all going to be correct um
well if it's a topic that you feel kind
of ideologically passionate about
uh then that's probably not true and in
some sense correct me if i'm wrong here
but this is an example
of you changing your mind right like
didn't didn't i read maybe i think in
your book
that uh at first when you first got into
this set of questions you were hopeful
like many people are
that better training and logic and
probabilistic thinking will make
everyone more rational
and you've you've kind of moved away
from that you have this amazing quote
that i want you know to get a tattoo of
our judgment isn't limited by knowledge
nearly as much as it's limited by
attitude right yeah it's it's um that
was kind of a hard lesson i learned over
the course of several years
um just observing people and observing
myself
and noticing that you know
knowledge and and thinking skill
are they're like a tool and you can
direct that tool
to any end you can direct it to the end
of
um figuring out what's really true if
you're motivated to do that or you can
direct it to the end
of you know coming up with with airtight
defenses of whatever position you want
to believe if you're motivated to do
that and so just having the tools
themselves
i mean it sounds almost obvious now that
i'm saying it in hindsight and
you know i guess it's kind of obvious if
you look at like
an internet forum where you know there's
all these people on the forum who
are are well armed with a list of
cognitive biases and logical fallacies
but all they do with that list is
you know point out how other people's
reasoning is fallacious
and you never actually see them question
anything that they believe
or you know turn that turn those tools
on their own reasoning
so that's why i guess maybe it's kind of
obvious but i haven't been fully aware
of it
i i don't think it's at all obvious to
be honest i think you should give
yourself more credit there and in fact
the very first episode of the mindscape
podcast was with carol tavares a social
psychologist
who's done wonderful work on cognitive
dissonance and how we rationalize all
the mistakes
that we make and you know i asked her a
little bit
after diagnosing all these issues like
what do we do about them and she wasn't
that
uh programmatic about how to fix
all of these problems that were in she
seemed to think it was part of the human
condition and we could sort of valiantly
fight against it but didn't have
anything specific uh
really as a as a remedy but here you are
so that
we finally uh two and a half years later
i think uh gotten to what the answers
are
here maybe maybe three years later oh my
goodness yeah we're approaching the
three-year anniversary of when i started
doing congratulations
this podcast we're not quite there yet
but we're getting there so um
and you you you approach this problem by
way of a metaphor
uh a military metaphor you want to
explain what that is
yes so uh i call it soldier mindset
and that's my term for uh broadly put
the motivation to defend your beliefs
uh or what you want to be true against
any evidence
or argument that might threaten those
beliefs
and the the metaphor comes from the fact
it comes from the way we talk about
reasoning and beliefs and evidence
um so it's the language is just it's
strikingly militaristic
uh when you actually look at it so when
we talk about
beliefs we talk about uh supporting our
beliefs or
buttressing our position the way you
would you know
like fortify a fortress um and then we
talk about
like poking holes in the other side's
case or shooting down
an argument um as if you know yeah we're
defending our forward against attack
and then when we talk about changing our
minds uh the language is almost
it's like we're admitting defeat we've
lost essentially
uh so just the idea of conceding a point
that the the word there is to seed as in
seeding territory
like in a battle um and then admitting
you were wrong or admitting that someone
has a point
to admit is like to let someone into
your you know into the gates or into
your fortress
uh so it's all about weakness and defeat
and
and so i call it soldier mindset uh and
it's it's just a term for what we've
been talking about motivated reasoning
um also known under other names and in
other facets
as uh rationalizing or wishful thinking
or denial or
um to some extent confirmation bias
so uh so so i wrote a book not about the
existence of soldier mindset because
other people have covered that
admirably already but about an
alternative to soldier mindset
which you're going to call the urinary
role scout mindset
which is the title of my book the scout
mindset and uh
and and that metaphor is that you know
unlike the soldier whose role is to
attack and to defend the scout's role is
to
go out and explore and see what's really
there and
uh and form as accurate a map of the
landscape or of
the situation as possible um and
the scouts you know may have preferences
like you you may hope to learn that
there's a
conveniently placed bridge across the
river where you need to cross
but above all you want to know what's
actually there you don't want to
draw a bridge on your map where there
actually isn't a bridge in reality so
scout mindset is then my term for the
motivation to
see things as they are and not as you
wish they were
i i actually really like this metaphor
uh i mean well one thing
that immediately came to mind is why do
we need a metaphor for just trying to be
as rational as possible like couldn't we
just
put the case forward as cold-bloodedly
rationally as possible
but maybe that's okay i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna give you a hard time about
that but
the metaphor uh even though i'm totally
on your side
in terms of having the scalp mindset and
it's a good thing
it actually suggests reasons why the
soldier mindset the sort of sticking by
your guns mindset
might in some circumstances be the right
thing right if we take the metaphor too
far
uh i mean soldiers if you're in a battle
they serve a purpose i probably want
more soldiers than i want
scouts right and and part of being a
soldier is
and it's the it's the downside of being
a soldier but it's the necessary thing
is
your job is not to think about whether
the battle is just
or not right your job is not to
think about the geopolitical strategy
your job is to
uh be on the ground or in the air or
whatever and
try to win your momentary little battle
and
if everyone was a political theorist and
a just war theorist in on the
battlefield
uh on one side i don't think that cyber
had a very good chance of winning right
i mean they would be
hesitant i always think in terms of
rather than battlefield metaphors i
think in basketball metaphors usually so
like there are people with scores
mindsets
right like when the ball is in their
hand they're looking at the basket and
they're going to shoot one way or the
other
there are other people who are
facilitators and they're not even trying
to score they're trying to set people up
to score and
both of those mindsets simplify their
jobs in some sense
so uh-huh is there some self-undermining
going on in this metaphorical choice
does it suggest that maybe
it's too much work for everyone to have
this scalp mindset
so uh a couple things uh first of all
it's it's
definitely not a perfect metaphor like i
i don't know if it would be possible to
have a perfect metaphor i considered
other metaphors like
uh like i thought about the judge and
the lawyer for example which some other
people have talked about
but the problem with that was that the
judge is very passive the judge is not
going out to
you know learn about the world and get
new information they're just considering
the information that's put in front of
them so that
that's kind of not ideal um
so so yeah i agree there's this kind of
potentially this connotation that um
you know we in the real world we
actually need soldiers um at least until
we've somehow achieved world peace
uh so that that's yeah you're right
about that and that's maybe an
imperfection in the metaphor
um but then to the kind of substantive
point of
well don't we need people who are not
constantly
thinking about things and second
guessing things and questioning and but
instead just acting
um this is maybe a subtle point but the
the metaphor that the term scout and
soldier mindset
are supposed to be referring only to how
do you decide what to believe
um so if you like picture
picture uh an entrepreneur who's they've
got this company they've created
and there's all these you know all this
uncertainty in starting a company like
are we targeting the right market and
is our like should our project our
product be improved more before we
launch it et cetera
there's all these uncertainties that you
could be constantly wondering about
um and i don't think that being a scout
means constantly
questioning everything you're doing um
because that would be
untenable yeah basically you have to
like you have to make the best decision
you can in like a limited
time period and then you have to act on
that decision for some set period of
time
either until like a good point when it
makes sense to
step back and and you know now it's our
quarterly meeting like what
what things should we change or or until
some new information comes up we're like
oh
we've like huh our sales numbers this
quarter were like surprisingly low
maybe now is a good point at which we
should like step back and revise what
we're doing
and so i definitely don't want to define
scott mindset as constantly questioning
everything
um i mean to define it as like having
having a quote unquote map in your head
of reality or of you know
how my business like what my business
choices are and whether they're
justified
and have having your map be uncertain in
all the places where
it should be uncertain um and then you
know you can like
pull that map out when you're making
decisions about
whether to change what you're doing
whether to pivot et cetera but you don't
need to be constantly staring at the map
and never moving okay does that make
sense
no it does make sense i just want to
keep pushing a little bit because
once again i'm totally mostly on your
side here and i'm just trying to sort of
push back it's great for pushback right
exactly so
because one of the things that i find
hardest about trying to be rational
especially in a social context
is that we do have finite resources
both of uh our cognition uh our
attention
our time you know a million different
ways and so
there are especially like the one that
i'm very familiar with is as a physicist
online there are a lot of crackpot
physics things going on
out there and there will be people who
just say like
you have a duty to look into this
because if it's true
it's it's going to be amazingly
important right right and if you don't
then you're closed minded yeah exactly
you know the m drive do you know about
the m drive
em drive i that sounds familiar but i
couldn't explain it to you it's a
talentless drive basically it's like
that they really believe the the analog
of
getting in your car and making a move by
pushing the steering wheel forward
so like they're just shining light on
one side of the spaceship from the
interior
and making it move and somehow
conservation of momentum is is violated
but
they they say that you know in a
basement in texas someone made it work
so
and i'm like no i maybe someone did make
it work there's certainly a chance
there's certainly a non-zero credence
that something like that works but i
have all this background knowledge
called like the laws of physics and
things like that right
and so this is beyond the pale to me
this is something i'm not going to pay
attention to and i think that's the
correct attitude but figuring out
exactly where to draw the line
between what's not worth paying
attention to and what's worth being
open-minded about seems to be the tricky
part
yeah no that's definitely that is
definitely the tricky part yeah
i and maybe you already understand or
agree with this but
i don't think i don't think there's
anything intellectually dishonest
or you know anti-scout mindset in saying
uh you know that could be true but it's
like i have limited time and information
and that's below the threshold of worth
paying attention to or worth
investigating now
and to be honest i think like the people
who are urging you
you know kind of guilt tripping you into
trying to pay attention to their fringe
claim
by you know exploiting your desire to be
intellectually honest i think that if
they were
like i i i don't actually think that
they would act that way about any
um any random fringe claim like i don't
think anyone can realistically claim
that every single fringe claim is worth
everyone's attention that just doesn't
really make sense
so this feels more like an exploit to me
like an attempt to exploit your
your desires to be virtuous don't worry
it doesn't work
my desires to be virtuous are not that
strong i can easily i can easily ignore
it but
but if i'm trying to be virtuous it's
not that i'm going to start paying
attention to them
but it's that i cannot exactly
articulate
where i should draw the line between uh
crazy ideas worth paying attention to
and those that are not because
i can be very honest and say that some
of my ideas are seen as crazy by other
people
and so how do i make the sales pitch to
them that well maybe they're unlikely in
your world view but they're not so crazy
you should ignore them like
that seems like a very hard meta
rationality problem to me
yeah it is hard and i don't have like a
clear-cut answer to it
um so sometimes
i think in theory the distinction that
we want to be paying attention to even
if we can't always perceive it perfectly
the distinction is between
dismissing something because your prior
beliefs
indicate that it is it is very unlikely
to be true
um versus dismissing something because
you don't want
to accept it or you like don't want to
take it seriously
so one is just like a it's just a
cognitive um uh
the judgment call is like purely
cognitive and the other hand it's
motivational
uh and so so sometimes what i'll do
is i will
sometimes i will pay attention to uh
whether
if if there were another theory that i
liked that was
um you know similarly implausible would
i feel motivated to check that out
instead um like i might i don't know
i might like the idea that uh
i'm trying to come up with something
implausible but also desirable
um well you know are ufos really aliens
yeah uh i would like it to know what my
desires
are about that actually i would like it
to be true okay well how about the end
draw
maybe like a clearer maybe like a better
way to express this is just um
if if you find yourself saying uh
that like i don't have like i can't
immediately find any flaws in that
argument but i just this like seems too
low probability to me
to look into then that's that seems much
more intellectually honest to me
than what many people do which is is
making making an argument against the
evidence um
that's that's maybe not even very well
supported but they feel like they have
to come up with an argument against it
to dismiss it
one of the best ways to keep yourself
young and your mind sharp
is to learn new things and there's no
better way than the great courses plus
streaming service with a library of over
13 000
audio and video lectures there's an
enormous variety of topics you can get
on the great courses plus and with a
great courses plus app
it's very convenient you can watch from
your phone your tablet or even stream to
your tv
i've done courses for the great courses
plus for example the physics of time
you can learn about why there's an arrow
of time due to entropy
but also how we tell time how time works
in relativity and space time
a little bit about the neuroscience and
the philosophy of time
i had a great time creating and
recording these lectures because it's an
opportunity to dig deeply into a topic
that everybody cares about
so what are you waiting for sign up for
the great courses plus today to start
your 14-day free trial
and for a limited time listeners of
minescape can get 20 percent off an
annual membership
this is only through the special url the
greatcoursesplus.com
mindscape that's t-h-e great courses
p-l-u-s
dot com slash mindscape
now that's a very good point so let me
let's try to restate it to see if i
understood it that
uh it's there are times when we're not
going to pay attention
give our resources over to seriously
contemplating a certain proposition and
the reason why is just because
it is so in conflict with our background
beliefs that we're going to judge it
very very unlikely and it's better to
offer that as the honest reason why
rather than to sort of come up with some
uh
barely plausible substantive reason that
pretends to
meet the argument on its own terms
yes that's very well put i don't think
it fully solves your
or it doesn't fully answer your question
but it's like one of the heuristics that
i would use
to try to be intellectually honest while
still not evaluating every single claim
um maybe another heuristic is just uh
to have to have at least some um
criteria for whether to investigate or
take seriously a claim
that are kind of kind of outside view
criteria unrelated to whether you
personally
want to reject it or accept it so for
example if
uh if if some like smart and reasonable
people
who i whose judgment i trust in other
ways
think that this claim is at least
promising or at least worth considering
um then i think that you know if i then
still
am am reluctant to even consider the
possibility that it might be true
or that it might be worth some people
investigating then that seems a little
suspicious to me
uh like yeah or maybe that maybe that
suggests another criteria like
if i don't want anyone to investigate it
uh and like if i get angry when anyone
takes it seriously
um then that kind of gives the lie to my
claim that it's just not worth my time
because i i do want like lots of people
investigating lots of fringe ideas
and and in theory you should be in favor
of that even if you don't
personally have time to look into
everything yourself well so right yeah
no but this comes
in exactly into uh where the rubber hits
the road kind of question
for people in academia for example where
you it's great to imagine everyone
pursuing every crazy idea but in the
real world you have not just limited
resources in terms of your own brain
but you're hiring people and you're
giving out grant money and things like
that
so how do you allocate grant money or
jobs to people who
are pursuing ideas you think are
probably wrong
right i mean that that's a very
difficult thing because well you think
it's probably wrong but there's a chance
that it's right i think it's very hard
it certainly is hard in practice to find
people who will say well i don't like
this idea but we should
hire them anyway because who knows what
i think right
yeah i mean these are all very hard
questions
and i would i guess i'd be shocked if
there was like an easy clear-cut answer
to them um just because it in practice
it so often depends on like
the particular logic of the case in
front of you where like
sometimes like if you can
if you can see a very basic you know way
in which the theory contradicts
you know extremely well-established
physics and the person either doesn't
seem to be aware of that fact or their
defenses of it seem
ridiculous to you yeah then i think it's
pretty reasonable to conclude that
they're
not that you know there's not some
hidden
brilliance there that you're missing um
but
you know in general i think we should
like
in general i suspect that the the bias
is towards being too unsympathetic to
like weird or fringe ideas just because
i think that's human nature
that uh we're you know
we tend to not like the the like
unpopular maverick who
uh you know has an idea that tells us
we're wrong yeah or that like
questions the consensus i think that our
bias is towards
being like less open to that than we
otherwise should and so
you know even though i don't want to say
everyone should get
all the funding and all the attention i
want to like err on the
air more on the side of being open as a
community as like a scientific community
i want to air more on the side of like
letting people investigate things that
most people think are wrong well i think
you said something there that i think is
actually
very true and very important i don't
want to let it go by uh too quickly
which is that one of the techniques we
can use
when we're judging these ideas that seem
to be unlikely it seems to me
is not just to think about the idea but
to think about this person who is
promoting the idea right and right
and to ask ourselves like when we're
listening to them
do they seem like a fanatical uh
demagogue about this like they're just
so focused on if they can't see the
opposite or
do they start by saying well i can see
why you would think this is crazy and
let me explain to you
why it's not that's always much more
persuasive to me i think so too
yeah and maybe there's going to be some
exceptions like people who are actually
right but just
you know bad at seeing the criticisms
but i think as a general rule that's
that matches my experience that people
who
who understand and can articulate the
like the reasons why their theory seems
implausible or or
why other people you know uh don't
already agree with them
if they can understand and articulate
those things and and still
you know say i think i think people are
still missing something
that is a good sign to me yeah so yeah i
would put that on my list of things that
would make me more willing to take
seriously
an idea that you know on the face of it
seems wrong well and speaking of which i
mean you have written a book and i
encourage everyone to buy the book it's
very it's very helpful i think i blurbed
it in fact
uh but and i don't want to give away all
the book here therefore here on the
podcast but maybe we can
give a flavor for it by giving some you
know uh very explicit
helpful hints or strategies or whatever
it is for
being more scouty yes uh oh so
so tips for being a better scout i think
so i mean
whatever whatever you think is the best
way of doing it i mean what
what happens when we put this idea into
action
uh sure i mean that there are so i
defined scout mindset in this kind of
abstract way of you know motivation to
see what's really there
um but we can we can make that more
concrete with some examples
yeah so scout mindset could look like
uh actively seeking out like critical
feedback about
your beliefs or about how you're how
you're doing like as a boss or as an
employee or as a partner
and you know actually trying to think
about the feedback when you get it
instead of
immediately jumping to your own defense
um or the defense of your ideas
scout mindset could look like well as we
were talking about a minute ago
um really trying to understand the views
of people who disagree with you
and understand them well enough that you
could uh you could
explain them uh and and explain them
compellingly enough that someone else
couldn't tell that you actually don't
believe that yourself so you're not you
know
inadvertently straw manning this idea as
you're explaining it
you did you did have a hilarious example
in the book about a liberal writer who
who said that uh the conservatives
should trust that they completely
understood where they were coming from
and then they did just a terrible
terrible job
of uh giving good concerns i read it
and i i admired that this person this
like liberal blogger who will go unnamed
um
i appreciated that they were at least in
theory trying to
understand conservative views but the
intent was just so bad
you know it was like it was it was like
a a cartoon villain
caricature of conservatives where they
were like you know i get i understand
you conservatives you
you think that that like the best thing
in life is for rich people to become
richer and that's just like that's
what's really valuable and like
and and i understand you think that that
poor people are all just terrible people
and should die
i'm i'm caricaturing a little but only
only a little bit um
right so that's that's like one facet of
scout minds that i would say being able
to
to accurately understand and portray the
views of people who disagree with you
um kind of a corollary of that is is
just being able to
point to some critics you have who you
think are reasonable
even if you don't agree with them and so
those could be critics in the sense of
people who disagree with your political
views your scientific beliefs
but they could also be critics of you
know your lifestyle choices
or your um the industry you work in like
if you work in tech or you work in the
military
um and i think what people typically do
and what i certainly
am tempted to do is to focus on the
unreasonable critics
because everyone has unreasonable
critics like there's always people on
the other side who are
who just are terrible and are either
like
right sorry oh my goodness yes
[Laughter]
uh yeah so there's always critics who
are either just like completely ignorant
or arguing in bad faith
and so yes those exist but if you if you
want to be a scout like you should also
be pushing past that
to look for the critics who may not be
quite so unreasonable and even if
they're wrong maybe they're wrong in
like subtle ways where you can
understand
how you know a intelligent thoughtful
person could
hold that view let me and so let me just
interrupt i just thought it was like
suspicious
i think we should find it suspicious if
you can't find any good critics
of your views or your choices that's
exactly i think i like that a lot and i
think that it's
i want to relate the the last two things
you said because they seem
you know slightly related versions of a
similar idea like one is
the idea that you can uh accurately
model
your opponent's point of view it's like
you can run a little virtual machine
in your in your head that mimics their
point of view
and then the other is that there you can
find a real person who has that point of
view
who that you respect and i think that
both of those are great
all in favor in the spirit of pushing
back
um i have people who
i uh respect enormously uh very very
smart and i disagree with
and so the example that came to mind
when i was thinking about this podcast
is actually david chalmers
because i'm i'm finishing up an article
about uh consciousness
and david chalmers a former mindscape
guest uh
is clearly super duper rational super
duper smart uh very open-minded very
nice guy like everyone loves david
chalmers
and i completely disagree with him about
consciousness and
i i i don't know what he thinks about me
in terms of being rational and smart but
he completely disagrees with me about
consciousness
and we've talked about it and we've
tried to be rational
and i don't think that either one of us
has changed our minds even a little bit
is there some worry that uh
the fact that there are such rational
people who disagree with us
points to the existence of these
disagreements being something that goes
beyond
rationality is it uh a mode of
communication
failure or just uh such big differences
in priors that no evidence can overcome
them or how should we think about that
so i this is another thing on which i've
my opinion has sort of evolved over the
last 10 years
um i think it now seems to me
much more likely and much more common
that two people even if they're being
perfect scouts
that two people could earnestly try to
resolve their disagreement over some
factual issue or some
um at least partly empirical issue
and fail to reach agreement uh on what
the correct answer is
you know even if they're both really
genuinely trying and both smart
uh that i think that seemed more
implausible to me
uh 10 years ago than it does now and
uh and that you know a lot of the
problem is just
as you kind of alluded to our prior
beliefs
um really do like even if you're not
suffering from motivated reasoning at
all which all of us are to a large
extent but like even in the perfect
world where we weren't
um your prior beliefs color how you
interpret the evidence and so
there are just these tangles of where
where it's it's kind of hard to escape
this um
this trap where you and i are both we
can't resolve our disagreement because
whatever evidence we look at
uh we can't agree on how to even what
direction that evidence should update us
because
the way we interpret the evidence is
colored by our prior beliefs and so
uh that does happen and it's you know
it's like philosophically interesting
and frustrating uh
i'm just kind of i do still think that
trying to trying to strip away the
motivation component
from it at least improves the situation
and
i have made progress on like
intellectual disagreements
um that i wouldn't have made if i hadn't
been trying to you know
remove or account for the the
motivational aspect
but but i still have to accept that that
doesn't mean you know stripping away the
motivational component
of reasoning isn't going to mean that
everyone is going to be able to agree on
everything
because that because of this no yeah
absolutely not i
wonder how much of it is just due to the
fact that beliefs don't appear
in isolation but they're part of like a
network of beliefs right
in my book the big picture i call them
planets of belief where you have a bunch
of beliefs that sort of stick together
under some mutual gravitational field
and if you think that you're just trying
to change someone's mind about one thing
you're actually trying to cause this
enormous phase transition in a whole set
of beliefs and
it's hard and maybe it will happen but
maybe it'll take ten years to
to achieve maybe just that's so well put
um
i wish i thought of that metaphor phase
transition but
yeah so you know often what we realize
or what i've realized after the fact is
that there were
people's attempts to change my mind
about one node of this
graph were doomed because there were
other nodes that
kind of in the background that i wasn't
even aware of that
needed to change first or needed to
change also in order for that first node
to change
um so one example that came up as i was
doing research for my book was
um it was an example of this pastor
named joshua harris
who uh he wrote this he's most famous
for writing this book
that if you grew up as a christian
teenager in the 90s or early 2000s you
probably had on your bookshelves it's
called i kissed dating goodbye
and he wrote it when he was just i think
21 years old
uh and and it's a book all about how uh
you shouldn't you know date or certainly
not have sex before marriage but even
you know even engaged in any kind of uh
like romantic relationship before
marriage because you have to remain
pure for your future spouse and
the book out a lot it became famous but
it also got a lot of pushback
um and a lot of people came forward and
said joshua harris your book
completely screwed me up and now you
know
either like people said well i got into
a romantic relationship
that was or i got i got married um and
it was terrible
because i had no past experience to help
me make a good choice
or they said you know even now that i'm
married even though i
remained a virgin before marriage now
every time i'm intimate with my wife i
feel like i'm doing something terrible
because i've
i've adopted this view of sex as like
dirty and it and
something that corrupts you and so
anyway all of these stories
people started sharing all these stories
about how they felt this book had been
bad for them
and joshua harris
who i think is actually a unusually
thoughtful and
um and well-meaning person he he heard
the stories and he basically just
discounted them
for for years because he just thought
you know these are these are exceptions
or these are
i don't know haters which is true
everyone every like famous book gets
haters and so
oh yeah you know he was able to dismiss
them and then
uh the moment when he first actually
took seriously the possibility
that his book might have been harming
people was after a
a different experience he had um where
someone in the congregation where he was
a pastor
uh basically there was a sex abuse
scandal and several members of the
congregation
uh it came out that they had been
sexually abused by other members of the
congregation
and he joshua harris had he was not
involved in the abuse but he had known
about it and he had
he had not encouraged i think he had
encouraged the victims to settle it
internally and not involve the police
right and and so then he realized after
the fact
oh that was i was wrong i should not
have made that decision i should have
let them you know like encourage them to
talk to the police um and he felt
terrible about it
and and then he had the realization oh
so you can actually harm people even
though you're really well intentioned
and trying to do good and maybe that
sounds obvious but until you i think
until you really live through it you
don't fully appreciate
that that can be true um and then once
he had that realization
then he thought oh maybe my book
actually harmed people because he had
all the time when people were
complaining to him about the book he had
this kind of background belief that
hadn't budged which is that
if you believe you're well intentioned
then you're not actually causing harm
and now that that note had shifted he
could he could actually
shift the the node that was about the
book in particular
does that make sense sorry that was so
long i just think it's so interesting
i mean it's it's uh i have a favorite
metaphor for this also that i actually
got from
jennifer well that my wife uh who did
research
on um changing people's minds for a
little while
uh yeah and so it's the metaphor of the
plateau
and you're gonna laugh but it's it comes
from barbecue
it comes from cooking uh pork shoulder
low and slow so you you know you have
your barbecue
uh your your grill or whatever and you
keep it at very low temperature 225
degrees and you put the pork shoulder in
there for hours right for like seven
hours it takes to cook this
and you it's all very scientific you
know you put a thermometer
in the pork and you watch the
temperature go up
and it plateaus so it'll go up the
temperature of the pork
linearly and then at around 150 degrees
it just stops it just stops getting
hotter even though it's surrounded by
225 degrees
ambient temperature right so what's
going on there well
the answer is scientifically what's
going on is that it
is still changing but it's giving off
steam
so it's sort of evaporating it's it's
losing its heat
uh or rather it's it's exchanging energy
with its environment
but by giving off steam rather than by
increasing in temperature
and if you just let it stay there for a
while usually the right thing to do
in practice is to wrap it in in foil so
it stops giving off steam
but if but eventually if you just let it
in there it would start increasing in
temperature again
and so i like this metaphor because
you can you can try to change the minds
of a person
or a group of people and not be seen
not be apparently getting anywhere like
nothing is happening
right but there is some change going on
beneath the surface that will eventually
lead to
the change you're looking for but maybe
you don't know
right right but the point is there's no
direct relationship between
the internal state of what you're
talking into in the external way that
they're presenting themselves right
right right or even you know internally
it probably
the way it often feels to me when when
someone is trying to change my mind is
that
my mind's not changing my mind's not
changing my mind's not changing
and then and then i guess often there's
kind of a state of confusion where the
the evidence
the evidence that conflicts with my view
has accumulated enough
that it's past the threshold of like
okay well actually maybe i'm confused
about what's true here right
um and then that's and then
either i stay confused which is often
the outcome uh
or or my confusion resolves into a new
and changed view of what's happening but
that those are those are like two phase
shifts i guess as opposed to a steady
linear
um change in my view but my hypothesis
which may be completely wrong
is that there are hidden variables in
the quantum mechanical language in other
words there are
things going on that are below your own
conscious perception
that make you closer or further away
from that phase transition
yeah and do you think those hidden
variables are um
are they kind of like the nodes we were
talking about where there's like
unconscious beliefs that are kind of
being
changed uh or are they yeah i think
you know i mean we know that neurons
right you know they they get a little
signal and it
they the signal they get is kind of
analog you know you get like a couple of
beeps here and there
but the output is digital like if the
number if the frequency of getting
inputs up goes above a certain threshold
then the neuron will fire
so i think that what we don't know is
how close
all of the different nodes in our
network are to flipping over and doing
that phase transition like our
external profession is still perfect
confidence
uh and some people really are perfectly
confident and other people are one straw
away from the camel's back being broken
right
right that's uh that's very well put no
idea if it's true but
that's this is the theory that i have um
good one of my favorite chapters i just
want to you know hit very quickly we're
approaching the end here but i do want
to
get get some more of these um
uh helpful hints if they want if you
want to find them real
world strategies on the table i think my
favorite chapter in the book was about
wearing one's identity lightly maybe you
could say more about that
yeah so the last section of the book the
last three chapters are about
identity and how beliefs can become part
of our identity
um in the same way that you know people
are very familiar with how political
beliefs are part of your identity
yeah for many people or religious
beliefs they're you know
in the sense that you know when someone
disagrees with them it feels like a
personal attack
um it feels like someone is stomping on
your country's flag or something like
that and that's that's like the
subjective experience of
someone disagreeing with one of those
beliefs that are part of your identity
and and i think politics and religion
are just you know the tip of the iceberg
there's so many beliefs that
can become part of people's identities
um i lived in san francisco
for many years and so uh beliefs about
like
which programming language is best can
easily become part of people's
identities and they can argue very
passionately and emotionally about that
um and so a
a common piece of advice about this
phenomenon
comes from paul graham who's a
technology
investor and an essayist he's written a
lot of great essays
and he has this one popular essay called
keep your identity small
where he says you know the more things
that become part of our identities the
uh the harder it is for us to think
clearly and so all else equal you should
you know let as few things into your
identity as possible
and and i think i love this advice and
i've i've you know gotten a lot out of
it
i just prefer a slight variant on it
which i call holding your identity
lightly
instead of keeping your identity small
and the the variant
the thing i'm changing here is that i
think a lot of people certainly
me after reading his essay tried to
just avoid identifying as anything like
you know i would say there's a movement
that i am a big fan of and i've worked
with called effective altruism
which is about basically trying to apply
rationality to the project of doing as
much good as possible
in the world and and so you know by in
keeping my identity small
i would be refusing to identify as an
effective altruist in case it
uh distorted my ability to think clearly
so
if anyone asked like are you an ea be
like no no i'm not an ea i just
i'm a big fan of them and i work with
them and i like
to agree with them and and so basically
it just started
it just started to feel a little bit
awkward like like
verbally to try to explain you know what
i mean and also
you know i do think like
if you support a cause or a position
um then identifying with it publicly can
help bring
attention and credibility to it and it
can you know you're lending your
credibility to the movement by
identifying as part of the movement
and so i don't want to i don't want to
encourage everyone to never
you know join any movement or political
party or cause because then where would
we be
so really i think the trick and i don't
i don't know how different this is from
what paul graham actually meant
i'm just kind of disagreeing with the
way that his advice is often implemented
and practiced by people
um i think what we you need to do is to
be able to identify
with causes and movements and so on that
you value
while still kind of keeping some
distance emotional ideological distance
from those uh positions
um so that entails for example
always having a separation in your mind
between like
this is what the democratic party
believes or like this is what you know
liberals believe or black lives matter
or whatever cause that you're part of
and here's what i believe and maybe
there's a lot of overlap but they're
still two separate things and
you know whatever differences there are
i want to notice them and
my support for these positions is is
contingent in the sense that
you know i will i will identify as a
feminist you know
up until the point when i think feminism
is causing harm or is wrong
and so just always being aware that that
you know
you're supporting the belief to the
extent that you actually think it's true
and helpful
um you're not the the support isn't the
most important thing
or i guess i said that wrong but um you
shouldn't be
supporting it just because it's your
tribe you should be supporting it to
whatever extent you think it's right
yeah i mean you can agree you could in
principle agree
entirely 100 with the positions of a
certain group of people
but agreeing with their positions might
not be the same as identifying as a
member of the tribe
yeah i mean it's a tricky distinction
yeah
yeah it's it's i mean it's often
internal like i don't know one person i
interviewed for the
for the book said you know he used to
think of him
he used to strongly identify as a
feminist um and what that meant in
practice was that he would often
feel compelled to jump into arguments
online where someone was you know
being wrong and like argue with them to
defend feminism
and and then he made a conscious attempt
to kind of hold that identity more
lightly and so now he says
you know if someone asks him are you a
feminist he will probably say yes
because
you know he agree he like has a lot of
agreement with the group
that calls calls themselves feminists
but internally it feels very different
so if someone criticizes feminism it no
longer feels to him like his tribe is
being criticized
like this group of ideas is being
criticized and maybe i agree or maybe i
don't but it doesn't feel like a
personal attack on
me um and if if they're right i want to
know if they're right
and you know if they're wrong then i
don't necessarily have to like jump in
and angrily argue with them
i think this is a tricky issue for me
personally because i do think that
i mean i know people who go so far as to
just reject all isms
right like i don't i don't like labels
that's part of what i'm talking about
yeah and but i get it but it's just so
informationally compact to give me the
label on what you want exactly
exactly that's what i was trying to say
yeah so
i mean just at the pragmatic level i
think that labels are always going to be
useful in some sense but then
so i think that's okay but that's sort
of a non-emotional response
right there is this much more emotional
level where you know so tyler cowan
saw our mutual acquaintance who was also
a previous podcast guest
um you know he uh once
blogged about you know some rules for
i don't know whether it was being more
rational or something like that but
what one of his principles is that as
soon as people
use the words democrat or republican you
know their iq dips by 20 points or
something like that right
um and i get where that's coming from
and probably as a
as an empirical statement it's quite
justified
but it seems like a recipe for a kind of
quietism right
like uh don't don't get too
invested in real world attempts to
change
things for the better because that
counts as a kind of tribalism is there
is there some tension there
between not ruining our own rationality
by identifying too strongly and not
committing ourselves to making the world
a better place enough
so i think what i'm trying to say is
that the
your end goal that the thing you you
actually care about and art are
trying to um trying to promote in the
world
is like whatever the thing is you
actually care about like making the
world a better place
and so whatever tribes you identify with
are hopefully the tribes that you think
are going to help with that goal
but you should you shouldn't be losing
sight of of what
the primary goal actually is like
helping make the world a better place
and so you you know
you should be on the lookout for ways in
which like cheering for the democrats or
supporting whatever the
latest democrat cause is um you should
be on the lookout for ways in which
those things don't actually help with
the goal that supposedly is your main
goal like helping the world be a better
place
and so i'm definitely not saying you
shouldn't be identifying with a party or
a cause
um but you know there are a lot of ways
in which
doing the thing that feels really
satisfying uh if you strongly identify
as a democrat or an effective altruist
or whatever cause
doing like the things that that feel
really good for your identity
are not necessarily the things that
actually help make the world a better
place or further whatever your ultimate
goal
is um so i have this this
the way i think about it is in this
graph of with two axes
where one axis is you know how strongly
does this action
um like validate your identity
and the other axis is how much impact
does your action actually make on the
world
and so you know some actions feel really
good for your identity but don't help
the world
like arguing with strangers on the
internet or
or just like i don't know putting a
bumper sticker on your car or something
that's not really all that helpful
or some things are are actively
anti-helpful or unhelpful like
um like attacking groups that are are
really pretty similar to you but but
have like 10 percent disagreement with
you
on what to do and it can often feel very
tempting to attack those groups
right because they all disagree with you
but not quite and so that leads to a lot
of infighting
um and so i think this is an important
benefit of holding your identity lightly
is that it allows you
to stay away from those actions that are
that are so tempting
for identity purposes and instead try to
find the actions that are
actually going to help you know make an
impact in the world
which might be things like um one
one group that i interviewed for the
book is a an animal welfare group called
the humane league
and they pivoted from their original
focus which was
kind of like splashy demonstrations
outside the houses of scientists who
were experimenting on animals
that's that was what they were
originally focusing on years ago
and then when their new director came in
david komen heidi
he pivoted the organization to focus
instead on
farm animal treatment um in part because
just
like running the numbers there's way
more farm animals in the world than lab
animals and so
if what you care about is improving the
lives of animals you can have a much
bigger impact by focusing on the latter
and the specific strategy that they
adopted which has turned out to be
like really valuable is negotiating with
large
agricultural companies to treat their
animals better
so for example to agree to stop throwing
male
chicks into grinders after they're born
which is
was like typical practice in
agricultural companies because male
chicks can't produce eggs
um but those you know billions of
chickens who are dying painfully
uh due to this policy and so anyway the
humane league has won a bunch of
impressive concessions from these large
uh agricultural producers but it's not
that strategy is not very satisfying if
if what you're thinking is i want to
fight for my tribe of you know the
animal rights activists against the evil
companies who are standing in our way
because negotiating with evil companies
is like exactly the opposite of what is
satisfying
if what you're motivated by is you know
fighting for your tribe
and in fact lots of other animal rights
activists you know resent them for this
for like negotiating with the with the
enemy but in fact what they're doing is
really impactful for their goal
i think that's super important actually
and maybe i can just say the same thing
over again cause i don't think i can say
it better than what you just did but
the you know if what you want is to make
the world a better place
you're going to have to work with people
you don't agree with or even like
right right and so or at least resist
the temptation to
get stuck in unproductive fights that
aren't actually worth fighting
yeah the purity gatekeeping is is one
example of uh
not necessarily making the world a
better place but at the same time
so just because i i just need to be
contrarian here um please
i do think that i try especially and
maybe this is just
because i'm old and patronizing but i i
try with
young people who are who are sort of
maximally identifying with some tribe
right like
they've discovered a cause and it could
be you know one that i agree with or
disagree with
um but they're really passionate about
it and i i
have this feeling like i should
encourage them to be passionate about
their
their little tribal identity that
they've discovered because they're
sincerely trying to make the world a
better place in some way
and they're just not the energy to make
the world a better place
often comes from these irrational things
is what i i guess i'm trying to say and
maybe that's not right
but um it's george bernard shaw right uh
no reasonable man all reasonable men
know that
they can't change the world therefore
all progress comes from unreasonable men
and maybe that's not right i hate the
definition of reasonable yeah i
understand
but i do think that there are a lot of
people who
it goes back to the soldier versus scout
thing right i think that there's a lot
of young activists on the right and the
left
who are soldiers right who are committed
to a cause and are passionate about it
and
even if i don't think it's the best way
to live your life i think that maybe
it's a it's a sensible phase to go
through or at least an excusable phase
to go through
yeah well i mean again i think it's
important
to separate out being extremely
passionate and driven
to solve some problem in the world from
being like extremely passionate and
driven
to like defend your tribe and and just
like to really prioritize the former
over the latter
and i'm not going to claim that you know
people who are soldiers and who see the
world in black and white and
you know uh and aren't like trying to be
objective i'm not gonna claim those
people never
change the world because clearly many of
them have so it's not like that strategy
never works
um and and given that that's kind of the
natural state of affairs for humans i
think
it makes sense that we see lots of
examples of that working um i'm just
trying to claim that i think
it works better if you could be
passionate and driven about impact
than be passionate and driven about you
know defending your ideology or
your tribe i think it would be better
it's hard to prove that because we'd
have to like do a study and i don't know
how we would even begin to do such a
study
um but at the very least i wanted to
show some exam like
at the very least i wanted to combat the
claim that you can't be an effective
activist that you can't change the world
while being a scout because there are
some
very striking examples of scouts who
have changed the world um
and i suspect that's a more effective
strategy even though i can't prove that
no i think it's a perfectly rational
claim that you're making whether or not
the evidence is for we'll have to gather
more evidence so
uh maybe to end up let's just ask the
medic question which you
i think explicitly address in your book
is it rational to be rational
uh where the word rational is being used
in just ever so slightly different
senses right there like is it
if i had some self-interest in being
happy or fulfilled or whatever
as being perfectly rational about my
view of the world the best strategy to
get there this is a great question and
one that
is one of the reasons it took me so long
to write this book is that i spent a lot
of time thinking about
you know potential challenges to the
thesis or
you know ways in which like potential
downsides to scout mindset
and so to elaborate on the question
that you asked um there's there's these
two different
senses of the word rational that we we
haven't really made this distinction so
far even though we've been talking about
being rational throughout this whole
conversation
um but one of the senses is epistemic
rationality
which is about uh it's basically the
sense in which i've been using the word
throughout this conversation
like reasoning um as accurately as
possible
um reasoning in a way that makes your
beliefs more accurate over time
um then the other sense of the word is
instrumental rationality which is about
uh whether the decisions you make are
effectively
achieving your goals or not um and so
the relationship between epistemic and
instrumental rationality is complicated
and many people argue that you know in
fact
the instrumentally rational thing to do
is often not
epistemic rationality like often if you
have a
you know deceived if you've
self-deceived in some way
that will you know make you happier or
that will make you better at
achieving your goals of say changing the
world or of making
like succeeding at some hard thing like
like making your company succeed
um and so you need to you know you
should be you should be trying to be a
soldier
uh in order to achieve your goals um and
i think this
so i think this is wrong in a number of
interesting ways
um but
the most important point that i want to
make is just that
in all of the specific cases in which
i've seen people say
you know oh yeah you have to be
self-deceived you have to be like
epistemically irrational in order to
fill in the blank in order to be happy
or in order to be motivated to do
something hard or in order to change the
world
in all of those cases i have seen
other ways you can achieve those goals
without having to deceive yourself
and so i think that a large thing that's
going on here is just that people are
um they're neglecting the possibility of
finding other strategies to get the
things they want and they just assume
they're kind of like giving up too soon
and they're assuming well you got to
deceive yourself if you want to be happy
or motivated
um and so one thing that i spend a lot
of time on in the book
is pointing out that you know oh you
don't
like let's actually take an example from
carol tavis's book
because you mentioned her earlier in the
conversation and
and towards the end of that book uh
mistakes were made but not by me
which is all about like self-justifying
behavior
uh she and her co-author kind of
have this fatalistic attitude of well
you know you can't
we have to self-justify because if we
didn't
if we didn't convince ourselves that we
had made all the right choices in the
past then we would be consumed by
uh regret and guilt and you know
and depression and i read that and i was
like
wait are those our only two options do
we really have to choose between
like convincing ourselves against the
evidence that we've made all the right
choices in the past
versus you know being depressed and
miserable
like surely there's a third option here
which is to
find a way to be okay with the fact that
we've made mistakes in the past and
still be happy despite that
like and i think this third way exists
in basically all of the cases that
people have presented to me
where they say you know you have this
choice between being happy and motivated
or being rational
um i think there's there's always a way
to
make p to a very at the very least make
peace with your situation that doesn't
require you to tell yourself false
things
i think that a place where this comes up
in my own experience with scientists
is i've known scientists really super
duper good scientists
who will explicitly say that the best
strategy
for let's say a theoretical physicist is
to be their
own ideas biggest advocates
because you know let everyone put
forward the best possible
uh view of their own perspectives and
the free market will sort everything out
uh whereas i tend to think that the best
that the
the good theoretical physicists should
be their own ideas biggest critics
so their most obvious you know their
most you know they put forward like
here's all the reasons why this could be
wrong but i believe it anyway as we were
discussing
before and i suspect that the ones who
say well i should be my own theories
biggest advocates
are are sort of cheating in the way that
you just to pinpoint it like they just
kind of enjoy being their own theories
biggest advocates
rather than thinking that's the most
rational thing to do well
you know they it can be a good strategy
if your goal is not
to like come up with a true
theory and have that theory be accepted
if your goal is just
to get a lot of attention or to get um
i don't know prestige or but i think
that's not true i think that
let's give them the credit that they're
actually trying to find the truth
because i think that is
true these are people who will change
their minds like just because they're
their own theory's biggest advocates
today
doesn't mean they're at all consistent
with what they were saying last year
right right okay so so really the this
question is just
should we want like setting aside one's
own selfish
you know goals for attention or prestige
or whatever should we want other people
to be their own biggest their ideas own
biggest advocates is that how we
want science to work uh and
in theory that could work if everyone
was uh
if everyone was sort of you know playing
the role of an ideal jury
and they were hearing the best possible
arguments on both sides for the ideas
but in practice that doesn't actually
seem to be the way it works
it seems like very few people are taking
the time to delve into the
the nitty-gritty of the arguments for
and against the theories and the
the i mean i'm speaking mostly about
social science here because i'm more
familiar with that than with physics
so maybe it's a little different than
physics but um
but uh it's not in practice like ideas
get
they get attention and they get
publications and they get ted talks and
articles um without all that much
vetting of
whether they're really sound and so if
you have people who are just
advocating for their ideas without
worrying too much about whether those
ideas are true
i don't see that process really weeding
out the true from the false ideas very
well
actually maybe this is an interesting
distinction between social science and
physics is that
i think in physics it's maybe clearer
more often
whether an idea is true or false like
you can do pretty conclusive tests
oftentimes and so if you have someone
really pushing hard for an idea
and then it fails in experiments um then
maybe that's just kind of clear cut and
the matter is settled
whereas in social science the
experiments are so rarely clear-cut that
you like ideas rise and fall much more
based on the advocacy of
their proponents than based on the facts
from the world
and so the problem i suspect that the
rough life cycle
is very very similar in both cases but
the time scales are much quicker
in physics because like you say there
can be very definitive evidence you go
all right i guess i will move on
or even a definitive theoretical
argument um whereas in social science
not to mention the humanities uh you can
cling
to your increasingly less likely
position for a very long time without it
going quite to zero
right yeah yeah i i guess the time
scales maybe that's what i'm
uh what i'm pointing at although at the
end of the day i don't know
the quality of the evidence that we can
get even in the best worlds
um or the best possible cases in
like psychology yeah i don't know
i feel like you can do a bunch of
experiments and kind of get whatever
answer you want
um with a little statistical wizardry
uh on either side so i'm not even sure
that like long time scales would help
the problem in social sciences if if you
have everyone just being
a soldier for their ideas exactly i'm
not sure that that process would weed
out the two ideas from false even in
long time skills
that's right so that speaks to the idea
that individuals not just communities
should be tough on their own ideas which
i think is ideally yeah
i think so i think it's a better way to
go and you know just to
sum it up you you you do want to make a
case for the emotional rewards of being
like this it's not just an intellectual
reward right it's a satisfying way to
live
i do yeah i mean i think you know i'm
not going to deny that it can be
comforting to tell yourself
you know false but convenient things but
it is you know i and
and many people i know find it very
freeing
to be able to follow the evidence where
it leads without
feeling like you have to believe such
and such in order to be happy or in
order to
you know feel good about yourself or be
motivated
um that i think it's very liberating to
not feel like you have to believe
something in order to
you know get what you want um and
you know there's lots of rewards of the
joy of curiosity and figuring things out
that i think
come from scout mindset um eve you know
regardless of of the uh of whether the
conclusion is something that you had
wanted to be true there's kind of a
a thrill of of seeing the world more
clearly than you had before
um and so you know as always i'm trying
to be like reasonable and nuanced and
i'm not gonna claim that soldier mindset
has no benefits but
i think the benefits of scout mindset
are underappreciated and that if more
people appreciated those benefits
um then they would they would like find
my mindset
much more doable than they think it is
it sounds very good to me but i promise
that if contrary evidence comes along i
will change my mind about that
so i would ask for nothing less from you
sean julia gallo thanks so much for
being on the weinstein
it was so much fun thanks so much
[Music]
you